uh uh listen we we can't use this stats
to say much because if we break those
stats down for reasons why and you look
at the pairings and you know how number
one reason is financial okay so let me
tell you something about finances yeah
as a man if you're meant to be a
provider if you are with a woman that
earns more than you she may leave you
but it's not always because she's August
and she thinks she's better than you a
lot of the time when you are more likely
to leave after a promotion yeah but wait
like a lot of the time when you are
doing more than your man is in the field
that he's supposed to be doing more than
you are because he's going to then act
out against you not because you he how
do you know they're not acting out
against him and acting like they're
better than him because he can go both
ways okay and that's why when we use
these stats we need to look at the
reasonings why because a lot of the time
men get really upset because their woman
is doing better than him and that makes
him feel emasculated to leave your
husband because he's upset no because if
he if he treats me like crap because I'm
making it because deep down he knows I'm
making more money he's making him feel
some type of way and he's not making me
happy of course I'm gonna have to leave
I'm not gonna like quit my job so that
you can feel better about yourself about
the kids happiness and not yours the
case happen is dependent on some of my
happiness but why because if I'm because
I think happiness is a choice
um it is a choice and that's why you
make the right choices if it's a choice
then why can't you be happy
well I can't be happy but if there is
somebody in my life that is he who's
happy unhappiness is affecting mine
because energies are contagious then I
have to separate myself especially even
for kids this is the thing sometimes we
think that for children the best thing
is for parents to be together no I mean
the best because statistically well the
best thing the best thing for kids when
when
um when they are young growing up is to
have a healthy loving relationship being
shown in front of them if you two are
not getting on as a married couple at
least separate but keep the love or in
for the child because at the end of the
day it's not about you and the person
being together about that kid growing up
healthy with mental and emotional
stability depending along why can't you
just live in separate rooms live in
separate houses why because living in
separate rooms well I want it's better
for the kids to have two parents in the
home you know what I genuinely but see
this is like a modern mindset where it's
like me me me first my happiness first
before my own children and like that I
think that's why we have like a very
[ __ ] up society today because it's me
me me my happiness me because your
happiness directly affects somebody if
I'm depressed
like okay if I'm in a terrible
relationship it's like okay you can just
figure out how to get along with people
well I think it's important right if if
they are important and put things aside
that you're compromising your values
you take in front of God I would say all
Society very much is about individualism
now because like capitalism is
fundamentally based on individualism and
so therefore you you feed into your own
values now so now when you're in a
marriage you think what do I want not
what my husband or partner wants right
now
problematic because it makes it more
competitive the market and it makes your
teaching I think it's a problem because
it's not supposed to be about you it's
supposed to be about the family exactly
supposed to be especially the kid like I
just think as a mother you should want
your kids to be happy Above All Else But
if you're sadden your relationship
surely that's gonna transpire our kids I
know but I'm saying I'm saying I'm
saying like why can't you just put that
aside but let's say raise your kid raise
your kids and then after that you could
focus on your happiness because it takes
two it takes two seven of the practice
is that as a child you learn by example
and if you watch your parents argue or
you watch your mum constantly compromise
her values and say fine learn not to
argue yeah but the fact you're not to
get learn to get along but what if
you're like I don't want to do that and
you always see your mum being like I
don't want to do that in your and your
father is forcing her to do that you
learn growing up that you're that what
you want doesn't matter and you just
have to force yourself to do what you
don't like and that could put you in
really harmful situations don't you
think you're saying to teach these young
girls to be complacent like see their
mothers just speak in placement of the
fact
put the family above you but some I'm
not saying I'm saying I I don't I'm not
for abuse so and completely if it's an
abusive situation that's different yeah
but but I think I think I think I think
wait okay I think happiness comes and
goes
and I think there were a lot of times my
parents have been married 30 years and
there have been a lot of times where my
mom maybe wasn't happy for a couple
years or my dad maybe wasn't happy for a
couple years but because of us they
stuck it out and they got happier and
they learned to work it out and they
learned to get along and I think a lot
of times in our society we we throw in
the towel before we've even really tried
and I think that's the average length of
a first marriage is seven to eight years
in a household rather not be together
like as a couple but in front of the
kids you can just be a united front yeah
but then you can live your own private
lives
but you live together like you see right
I think if you're going into on a
marriage thinking that you're going to
be happy you're going in for the wrong
reasons because just like Pro said
they're going to be situations where
you're not going to be happy just
because you're not happy you're gonna
leave now no if you if you stand before
that Court you stand before you sign the
paper you agreed to death to life to
worse to better and not just because
you're happy you have kids involved
though it's not about your happiness
anymore because the fact that you two
gonna stay there that's gonna that's
gonna greatly impact the child's life so
if we're not talking about no extreme
cases about you know like any um you
know sa going on at home and any abuse
or whatever
in your I don't want to put it so
bluntly but it's not about your
happiness your life is not yours anymore
you're raising kids now that's the sense
of your life so forget your happiness
work it out look at our grandmas talk to
our great great numbers they went you
think that they're going to hell right
they will see their man cheating but
they say look I got kids so I gotta put
my kids before me because I know they
need me in the house and I think that's
like even you said we become way more
individualistic now and is that even to
our benefit look at the results it's not
doing us any good okay so just taking
off what you said and the whole it's
about the the family so your idea of
it's about the family is okay let's just
say you're like because you're talking
about a very specific situation the ups
and downs of a marriage where you can be
unhappy happy happy that's fine and I
think most people would agree on you you
need to ride the highs with the lows but
if you've got a situation where let's
just for the sake of this argument we've
got a woman and her daughter or even
like actually even flip it a man and his
son and that's this dude is habitually
unhappy like every day just unhappy
miserable whole family feels it all the
kids feel it you're like yo but you're
staying there you're putting your family
first but you're teaching this boy this
is what marriage looks like this is what
wait wait this is what a family looks
like so he then goes on to have his own
family where he's habitually unhappy and
then he teaches his son to do so you
have this line of people just unhappy
but married but like this idea of a
family together wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait let me just let me just
something about happiness it's about
Duty exactly
and I understand that but I don't think
like because to me you're like as long
as you are together that's the most
important thing and you stay together
like even if you're unhappy even
basically it is
because you're more likely to run away
from home you're more likely to go to
jail you're more likely to get bad
grades in school every statistical
disadvantage you can put a kid at
they're at when you take the father out
of the home what about yourself and so I
what I'm saying is that it's marriage is
not about happiness it's about Duty okay
and then my best friend everyone's what
Mario best friend have a baby with your
best friend like is your friend with
benefits but you have a child so it's
easy because you respect each other you
love each other and you don't really
need to argue
regardless there there is going to be an
unhappy time and like I said we can't
base a marriage off of happiness because
if if you come into a stinking look I'm
gonna get married with this love of my
life because they treat me well and
they're gonna treat me like a queen I
can be happy for the rest of my life no
because they're gonna be a day you might
go to a financial hardship you might go
to a health situation is that going to
be the breaking point you're like okay
no I'm not happy not going to leave no
you got kids so you're responsibility if
I had to take why can't we figure out a
solution just tell them like if you're
really unhappy why can't you figure out
a solution maybe maybe it's maybe it's
sleeping in separate bedrooms for a
couple years till you figure out how to
maybe maybe it's wait sorry maybe it's
marriage counseling maybe it's sleeping
in separate bedrooms for a couple years
maybe be it's I don't know consoling
with your church family whatever it is
but it's like why why is the first go-to
always divorce divorce divorce I
understand that and I get that in a cake
yeah I get that and okay I get that in a
case where you're like you've got two
people and they both like you've at
least got two people and they're willing
to work on it or whatever but what if
you've got a situation where you have a
person who is like I want to stay and
let's just say it's fundamentally there
are these things you do that make me
unhappy and that person like I'm not
gonna and right so you should carry so
you so what's the answer then like if
you've got this situation where someone
is like I'm doing my thing and I'm
living and I'm not changing so the
unhappy person example of an actual
situation okay cool so to like narrow it
down so 100 uh you've got a man and he's
married to a woman and he fundamentally
is like so so to me the underpinning is
this is my thinking he chose wrong when
he married this woman okay and the
reason is he wants someone who
fundamentally is submissive to him
that's what he wants and when that
doesn't when that doesn't manifest he
feels belittled in himself in front in
front of his kids in front of his family
and this woman does
she submits performatively so she's like
oh yeah I'll cook for you I'll cook but
when they have an agreement and he's
like I need you to move right she's like
nah that's not a good enough reason I'm
moving left and that constantly happens
they go to through therapy and that's
essentially the Crux of it she's like I
wasn't raised that way
um like my mom wasn't like that I'm not
gonna be like that whatever so and this
man is now happy she is not happy you're
like for Duty sake the family stay
together anyway yeah and I think Mariah
should be based on sustainability like
can she sustain that long term no I
would say until the kids are 18 I would
do everything I could to figure it out
until the kids are 18. what just give up
all like sense of morality and happiness
and like even if it is jeopardizing with
your mental health and like even things
like that like just stay what do you
mean all sense of morality like he was
saying about like oh that's how my
mother was raised like if it's going
against your morals in there like for
like not forcing you but like asking you
to be someone that you're not like
that's you're giving up all sense
I will give Will Smith a divorce
people Grant Batman
of your parents relationship and if you
watch your mum or your dad constantly
belittle themselves and constantly let
themselves get walked over you're going
to let yourself get walked over because
if you're their gender because it's more
likely to be the woman you're going to
think oh it's okay it's more likely to
be the woman because like domestic
violence you're more likely to be
domestically abused especially most most
um domestic violence is two-sided like a
lot of girls claim domestic violence but
they hit first okay um and you're
actually more likely to be in a domestic
violence where if it's one-sided abuse
like women are more likely to be in uh
more likely to hit men one-sided than
what men are to hit women okay fine well
whatever gender is your whatever gender
gets belittled you're if you're that
gender You're Gonna Let Yourself Go
walked over like that but do you think
people should just like never get
divorced is that like your position yeah
like do you think divorce should just be
like illegal like yeah
okay we'll sniff a divorce you said that
like you said that they should try their
hardest is Johnny Depp married I'd give
that man a divorce you like in some
situations divorce is legitimate you
acknowledge yeah
I think in front of we said you made
your bowels in front of God
has less value
so much
to you not not to people wait wait wait
wait wait not to people of Faith but
statistically but this is the as a
country we have belonging but not
believing true true however however
that's why marriage is outdated that's
why why we're in a post-meritable
society that's why that wait wait that's
why people are getting married less and
less and less what's people's
justification that they're saying the
marriage isn't working out because they
can't say anymore God God wants me to do
this what do they say to themselves when
they're unhappy and they're in a
situation it's about my kids
you do acknowledge there are situations
where divorce is acceptable to you of
course yeah like okay but here's my
point
do you not think the two people involved
in that marriage are the best people to
judge when that situation has arrived
yeah I think if that was true I don't
think it would be a 50 divorce rate
I don't think
I remember one reason wait I don't think
the number one reason would be
financially yes but that doesn't exist
in the vacuum though like there is other
things like that that changes when you
add more details like are they more
educated than it like I think it lowers
or if they're if they come from a
two-family home where everyone is still
married then it goes up like it's there
are things that change yeah it's bad so
it's not like you know every time you
get married it's a coin flip it depends
on your personal situation and things
going on some situations that are better
and worse true yeah and there's some
situations you're like you should get
divorced in your mind yeah exception's
not the rule I don't I don't think 50 of
marriages should end in divorce and my
whole point but like you're missing my
point because you're trying you're
trying to like get me I'm not I'm not no
but
wait wait and it's the whole point is
that we have a me me culture where it's
me and my happiness before the family
and where I think I should put my
feelings before the family in extreme
situations sure I believe in divorce
Will Smith I don't of Johnny Depp was
married to that woman but I'll give you
both divorces I'll get wait wait I'll
give you both divorces but in general
it's like we just have such a selfish
like modern women are selfish yes and
and it's weight and and it's about me
before my family and I just think that's
wrong but it's reflective of the society
we like in the UK in America we have
very capitalist societies and that is
individualism and if you were in a more
socialist society where it was more
about the community then you would find
families wouldn't splurp as often and
and the fact is it's not just women and
like men and women equally
women are the ones leaving women leave
70 to 80 percent of them
wait when women leave 70 to 80 percent
of the time 90 of their college educated
if anything I think women have become
more selfish because we're built out of
every bad decision
wait yes
wait wait no I'll tell you yeah because
every time we make a bad decision we're
bailed out if we're bad with our money
there's women's shelters if we sleep
around there's birth control if we get
pregnant we can have an abortion it wait
if we if we don't get the abortion and
we get married they can we can divorce
them and take half if we or we can put
the kid on child support child support
not Ted as well
um when it comes to marriage
that there's there's almost no incentive
for a man to leave
um more often than not there are men who
are just you're still breathing about
dying everything as we're speaking right
now so it's like
what you lose from a man leaving the
marriage in comparison to women even
marriage it's just it's more
incentivized for a woman to leave it's
just facts as a man a woman's going to
take off your money and you probably
won't have access to your kids that's
why it's cheaper to keep it you know
yeah most men will literally rather just
like just fade as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible